thank you
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
today we have adelia in the house
Deals
they should do um Asian cupping
treatment because I see you got Littles
circles yeah I did I did I thought I
covered it with the puffy sleeves
it's welcome in this area oh yeah two
can you see it check it out check out
the spread culture it's all it's just
it's just ladybug tattoos
no I just get cuffing a lot because like
when I work out it just I'm sore all the
time and I sleep on my side a lot and
you're not supposed to do that
so I just get cupped because I'm always
in pain did you always get injured I get
injured all the time I actually I met
him on crutches yeah
I currently have a sprained ankle but
I'm like on the two week Mark so it's
like I walk fine
um
they gotta see the video of you it's on
video like her spraining it's pretty bad
um I was trying to do the whop dance
all right
oh that sounds bad yeah let's just show
let's turn it around okay
start over you explained it too early
[Laughter]
oh my God is your tailbone okay God oh I
think so
yeah yeah boy it just goes so we can see
fail videos so we can see all these fail
videos of you on a special website uh
actually
Tick Tock that um you went and sprained
it again no I I bought ads
you have to say that
yeah that's true yeah let's get a little
promotional buy a little push on it yeah
how did you two meet at Kazumi's party
yeah I better there she was coming up
the castle steps on crutches I I
sprained it that day oh my God yeah it
was fresh it was fresh but the pain
hadn't like set in set in yet so Sunday
was a lot worse than Saturday so it took
me two hours to put on my pants because
I was by myself with a sprained ankle
are you one of those people that like
overshoot their own athletic abilities I
was well yeah
I was with a dance instructor yeah oh is
that who came in the frame is that he
was like running in yeah and he gave you
the confidence that you could do it yeah
uh we're not trying anything crazy I'm
not gonna do the jump kick ever again I
didn't even that was the first move the
first move is the from the top that I
sprained that that is in the first two
seconds that's why it was a quick video
and so soon in the clip I got it online
though so the video overall was like
about an hour and a half long and then I
sprained it at the end and I was like
turn it off I don't I don't want people
to see me cry I had like a few thousand
people on oh because it hurt that bad
yeah and I cry a lot but I don't get
embarrassed by many things that I would
get embarrassed crying on life
and you said how many times have you
sprayed that answer this ain't going for
taking at least 30.
yeah what do you do [__] Dances all the
time
I used to do cheer and hurdles uh those
are those are the ankle Sports over
shooting the limit yeah yeah
I used to
use it yeah yeah so I sprained both my
ankles and my knee and then I was out of
track for the hall where did you grow up
um Manhattan Beach so I used to drive to
Palos Verdes and ride my horse and
that's where I developed a huge hatred
of chicken so I don't feel guilty when I
eat chickens freak out horses no they're
just they're rude and they
yeah you like Farm to Table the chicken
did you like
Farm to Table what is that oh no
I call people to kill spiders in my
house
yeah you got a spider guy
yeah I got I got my house sprayed
because I can't kill anything
no it's I just started being able to
kill mosquitoes because of how allergic
I am
malaria free since 2023. [__] mosquitoes
yeah mosquitoes are the worst songs yeah
yeah so a horse fell on her yes should I
pull that up you have the video you have
the video of the horse falling I wasn't
on live I was actually in a competition
and I uh didn't feel how bad it hurt
because you know there's like the
adrenal Austrian uh bear racer A what
racer Barrel oops no no where they go
around barrels oh did the horse trip or
something what happened uh so actually
it was the the ground the chicken that's
why she hates chickens
oh wait no that's the horse took a dive
actually you know why don't you airdrop
it to me okay and then I'll play it on
this one so you like ride right yeah
yeah I used to compete how did you get
into riding horses uh how old were you
uh I was like four they were my only
friends because everyone hated me
too I'm gonna do it at four yeah I I do
think it was the church's fault
um spreading rumors immediately
understand now no I I grew up super
Christian so and then they would
basically tell you like you get bonus
points of Jesus if you can convert
people so I would try to convert four oh
yeah yeah no I was like in kindergarten
telling the Jewish kids like I want you
to go to heaven
please come to church
um so I under I understand why people
hated me so early damn oh there you go
everybody see this and yeah
there we go yeah
my name is Nutella
whoa oh my God
so I got back up and won actually oh and
then after the adrenaline wore off I was
like someone needs to help me get off I
was like specific
Ally
um actually I saw like two I think it's
it's like very small like two
millimeters of missing cartilage in my
left hip now and then I sprained both my
ankles and my knee and I was I was
pretty down bad for a little bit oh [__]
wow so how how did you get from riding
horses to only fans oh wow there's a lot
that happened in between
um when I was 18 I started a rave and I
just started a rave like no two Rave
like I started like hard stuff it's like
a deal your deals
Festus insomnia
influenced us
and at first I started raving because it
was just a cool place to do drugs and
then it transitioned slowly I was like I
love dubstep I like love punching the
air and like being really aggressive
dude yeah yeah why does everyone from
Manhattan Beach love raving I had a DJ
buddy out there that took us to all the
Raves I feel people parents in Manhattan
Beach like people wondered why I started
partying so young like there were 14 15
year olds going to Coachella without
parent supervision I'm like yeah super
young over there and then my parents
sent me to rehab for weed when I was 17.
um got sent to Utah Southern Utah with
the Mormons
I smoked once every two months like and
then you had to go to rehab for that I
failed one drug test my mom tried to
catch me for a year oh my gosh that's
like that's just socially responsible
and mature so I got kidnapped by two
people saying you're coming with us and
I'm like [__] you're not all right like
[__] I'm not and then they showed me
their stab wounds of kids actually
stabbing them they're like you want to
play this game and I was like not really
that's how they took you to read it yeah
it's been a bus they [__] Slide the
door and then they throw you in it
wasn't a bus it was just like a car with
two like jacked up people and they were
like if you try to run we'll get you and
how did you know that this was like
legit and not like a yeah well my
parents were behind them and they're
like they're going
yep that's the one yeah that's my
daughter by the way go for the ankles
yeah so then when I got out of rehab I
was like I just want to take a lot of
ecstasy went to Hard Summer and I was
like oh my God I love raving and I guess
rehab was not a rehab
it was the gateway drug because it went
from weed to [__] ecstasy I took
ecstasy
my friends kind of drugged me when I was
like 14 15. and I say kind of because
they gave me something that was called
ecstasy I'm like what is it they're like
it's fun and I was like is it like weed
because I tried weed and they're like
yeah it's just like weeds yeah
took it at school it's way better at
school yeah I took it at school because
I thought if it's like a weed that's
true why wouldn't I be highest she's in
school like oh my gosh
School must have been fun though I know
I hopped to the fence somehow blew three
guys that day
wow yeah yeah but you're very passionate
that day yeah you must have had the best
[__] no it was probably the worst
[__] imagine lockjaw with a dried up
mouth trying to get mad
yeah no I think it was probably the
worst book I mean they were 15 probably
the best because we were friends oh
that's the best yeah just feeling
anything I never forgot that yeah and
you bust so fast today's video is
brought to you by hellofresh
with the cost of groceries going up and
up now is the perfect time to get
started with hellofresh hellofresh is
cheaper than grocery shopping and 25
percent less than takeout hello fresh
has 40 weekly recipes to choose from
that's a lot from when they first
started yep for all meal occasions
Lifestyles and preferences take your
pick for meals like soy glazed salmon or
mushroom and chive risotto wow you know
what I like about hellofresh what is
that there's barely any food waste
because when you're a single person or
maybe just the two of you you know some
people go to a major markets and buy so
many things right and the whole fridge
is all filled up and when you open it up
you know half of that [__] gets rotten
yeah but for us when you get the
hellofresh the meals are ready and
divide it and portioned out where the
ingredients there's no leftover you just
chop it up you get everything ready and
if you don't finish it I guess there's
leftover food but you're not gonna have
like five extra carrots that are just
waiting in your refrigerator you're
gonna have like all these extra powders
and condiments just sitting there like I
think it's amazing because you know at
the end of the day I don't like food
waste so if you want to go ahead and get
some delicious meals without having all
this rotten food in your refrigerator
and you got some delicious yummy stuff
go to go to hellofresh.com off the
Record 60 and use code off the Record 60
for 60 off plus free shipping
[Laughter]
but yeah then after rehab I remember
everyone told me how cool Coke was and I
at first I thought cocaine was the
craziest drug so then about a month
after I uh came out of rehab I was 18 my
pants just randomly drug tested me 12
hours after I tried Coke for the first
time they always catch you when you're
like not even doing it all the time yeah
I guess for the first time always
catching no my parents always caught me
your parents are always right my so my
mom literally almost time to test my mom
was about so actually funny story so my
mom she basically she started her own
like insurance company she was like a
franchise State Farm whatever and then
she would just hire people to do work
for her so she never had to work really
except from home so she bought this like
old wooden chair with a cut out circle
in it for me to take my drug test in so
that I couldn't fill it up with toilet
water
yeah Colonial drug testing
yeah because uh funny story too she
drank my pee once no way what the [__]
yeah uh to prove a point that it wasn't
my pee in that it was toilet water but
still I just prove a point and uh no it
was half key half toilet water so she
was kind of right she was half right she
was halfway
[Laughter]
do you and your mom have a good
relationship now or ever or kind of it's
more my dad that I have beef with this
he sent me screenshots of my nudes about
a year and a half ago oh whoa yeah no
it was just weird he sent me this long
ass test like someone from the church
who you were really good friends with
and I'm like I don't think I'm good
friends with anyone from the church so
weird for like just from the start right
and then they told us I was browsing on
only fans and I can't believe I found
you
sit around only fans
for kitchen Sinners dude someone who
hates you at church sent it to them
basically basically they texted my dad
being like your daughter has a podcast
where she talks about sex and drugs and
her only fans and she has at that point
I don't think I had a sex tape yet but
they're like she's eating out girls or
like something like that like that's a
strong tea how does this person know
your whole body of work well they they
would either have to like I feel like
they had to be on my only fans five
bucks a month for this and 20 bucks a
month and after the third month it's not
a great deal here you get a discount
okay by the year though Savannah March
feels pretty good though so my dad
didn't take it at that he was like oh
you know what they sent me this text out
what my daughter does I'm gonna have to
look up her only fan so he found me on
Reddit had a screw she took a screenshot
of my Reddit where it was me nude like
it was like me on the floor taking a
mirror pick with my vaginas he had to
take a screenshot of it send it to me
and be like this is how you're
empowering woman you should be
embarrassed and ashamed Bobble and I'm
like you couldn't just take it at face
value that someone told you I was naked
on the internet you had to find it to
send it to me he's like I had to save
the images
what did you do to reply I blocked him
you blocked your dad yeah he's been
blocked for about uh almost two years so
you don't talk to him at all um I had to
see him at Christmas which was really
like it was there was just some other
family stuff going on where I had to be
home but I told them that he couldn't
talk to me could it could only direct
like conversation to the group as a
whole but couldn't talk to me oh like
tell Adelia to pass the salt
but like it's deals
is that
um I was told that he showed his friends
a conversation being like did I do
anything wrong
well he shows your naked guys he posted
Reddit am I the [__]
and then he shows the naked photos like
did I do something wrong so he I mean
just from the way it sounded from the
person who told me yeah they saw me let
me check those pictures these photos
right here see that's all the whole
church the next sermon they have you on
a [__] Powerball butt ass naked this
is my daughter did I do anything wrong
amen I know amen amen and then they have
to take a bathroom break you're doing it
wrong right now holy spirit for sure
dude from your point of view do you
think they did do you think like the
crazy like religious upbringing like
made you this way no this is just who
you are no I mean I felt like ashamed
like I was over there in fourth grade
watching anime porn not real porn
because real porn watching real people
naked would have been
when I was in Middle School I was
watching like Jersey Shore and like
girls next door and being like I really
want to be like that but like the church
looks down on them so it's like I felt
ashamed until finally when I was a
freshman after I gave my first [__] I
was like you know what [__] Christianity
I Just Want to Have Fun
because it's like why should I feel
ashamed for something that feels good
what do you think it would take for you
and your dad you should have been
Japanese
you fit right in yeah to rekindle the
relationship well it's actually crazy
because like he told me that he started
getting um like outside help for just
kind of how he's acted and then I looked
up the website that he was like oh [__]
what is it called like Christian Singles
it's like focus on the family and I
looked it up and it was like it
basically was like are you mad your son
is gay and I'm like this is what he's
getting help from like I don't take that
[__] seriously because it's just like
homophobic it was transphobic so I think
it's going to take a lot of him doing a
lot of inner work because it's like I
can only be called a horse so many times
before I even lost my virginity yeah do
you do you have any siblings yeah yeah I
know cool with them yeah I'm cool with
him yeah so uh where do you think like
got you so far from your parents like
lifestyle philosophy all that because we
grew a fellow Christian too yeah
um was there like a point where you're
just like
yeah this ain't for me after I get my
first [__] that's when you were like
yep I like giving
how was your moment yeah that was my
moment yeah no did you say it out loud
at the same time huh you're like hey
this is Christianity sick threw the dick
to the side it was just like but it was
also weird because my boyfriend at the
time was still very Christian and he's
like we can't lose our virginities
because that would be breaking
Christianity oh you were really
navigating yeah yeah right but no but
like any act like sexual acts is
technically against Christianity and I
remember like one of our fights was like
I was over it at that point and he
wasn't and then turns out he was texting
a bunch of girls so I lost my virginity
to his best friend it wasn't even like
that it was just I was kind of ugly back
then and he was the only guy down for me
oh no it's okay I had to glow up like
all these guys from high school are like
when did you get hot I'm like probably
when I bought my tits I don't know
that is so interesting yeah I remember
that trying to navigate around all the
Christianity rules and then you realize
oh wait even though the poop loophole I
didn't do that but the even like it's
funny because even the thought of it is
already of the sin so it's like oh we've
sinned so far back we might as well just
do it baby
you can't fall through right I feel like
those loopholes were the best though you
would always run into it somehow but
there's always a loophole like uh kind
of sleazy but like on the guy side of
things you're trying to navigate for the
girl yeah it's kind of like super
[__] scumbag but you're like no babe
it's cool
I was the opposite I was like we're
doing the opposite yeah I lost it to a
Buddhist you just gotta find outside of
the realm
yeah it makes it sound like a monk
in the Garb no hair you know how you
make up all these like rules of what's
not simple right yeah so in my head I
figured that well if we were both
virgins then it's kind of marriage under
God anyway right yeah
we just didn't have a ceremony and she
and she's my girlfriend
really married yeah you find any reason
to just do it like as a guy you're like
come on let's look through the Bible
it's like something
he did it yeah oh Methuselah did it I
was over here taking like I took I think
six virginities being like it's not a
big deal the scalp collectors
virginities I'm pretty sure if I looked
at my list I'm pretty sure it sucks wow
congrats so so the school you went to
Growing Up was the most like Christian
School no no it was just like my parents
and like the church I was at no oh you
didn't go to Christian School no no no
no but like they had me go on like
mission trips and stuff in middle school
and he's the mission
[Laughter]
Master you ever asked your dad like have
you ever [__] mom yeah no not once
he's like at least twice like you made
two of us [__] dude we did get really
drunk and he made jokes about peeing on
my mom not just saying actually taking a
piss on her whoa what was the context
what was it like a family gathering
knock knock joke yeah yeah I think we
were playing what what is that card game
like Cards Against Humanity oh and he's
like yeah I pissed on your mom it was
something like and we were like so you
[__] shamed me all the time but then my
dad is over here give a golden shower
man golden showers could have been a
jellyfish we don't know if there's
jellyfish what'd you say about strippers
my dad loves strippers love strippers I
think they're [__] but love strippers
so he's okay so he's a fan he's ashamed
that he's a fan yeah he used to go to
Vegas with my uncle and be like yeah all
the strippers love us and I'm like if
you weren't paying them they probably
wouldn't let's be real but yeah who says
that though you know yeah he's like
everyone says everyone says that you
know they they like me because I'm young
I like other guys
has demons for sure oh you gotta get him
drunk I think that's the way to do it he
he does get drunk yeah
I think some mushrooms or something in
his food or something he got mad at my
mom he got mad at my mom for even trying
CBD like that's not even [__] weed
the CBD yeah what the [__] yeah
[Music]
foreign